[Music]
Hey epic megalovania that's a meme
remember that one kids welcome to the Y
to show where I I do something yeah yeah
[Music]
okay all right all right I'll ask
petition to peers dad to someday
randomly enter pedes room and say are
you winning seven okay all right that's
kind of funny
are you winning some why does he look
barely older than pewds yeah welcome to
my entire life your dad is so hot Felix
yeah here's who thinks felix has hot to
stab I mean me me huh
I'm glad I'm a shadow and never winning
I've been losing my entire life because
of my dad up in heaven are you waiting
said I got a feeling we're gonna get
another one once we scroll down we're
gonna get another one it's an exquisite
taste when you realize that the only
reason Pierce doesn't have legs is that
G fuel needed something not true not
true at all I swear
namaste I grew up watching Pokemon so
it's Swedish I grew up watching
PewDiePie series India by Tyson Charlet
a hot pie what the hell is bye I guess
uh chal raha hey Mike hi such aa raha a
where's Galya
come on disappointed there's no gay line
how's it goin brooch what's the point
Petey pie when he kills a pie or I don't
know didn't watch it die pipe you this
is the top voted this is the top voted
this week 50,000 people yeah this is the
reason I came up with the goddamn name
to begin with
and you're using it as a joke me like oh
my god if you use P yeah that's the
point
pew pew pew Zoomers god damn my god damn
it
how's it going fellow 69 years dad I
can't wait to be 69 that's gonna be epic
ah only reason I look forward aging 69
oh my god
beep I change on pew they buy nice
that's one of Martin's favorite anime
that's so funny it's a really old comedy
Japanese I think it's a comic manga blow
my mind hmm
my is older some of its viewers damn
that's really weird to think about
mine's 14 nice a threat people making
those cooking videos set those up just
to screw me over
stop it cooking videos I'm done with you
I'm done with you dude stop making
sandwiches I'll actually next episode of
cooking repeater pie we're making
sandwiches and you're the ones that
gonna be trolled we're making mother
flippin connect your brow next time and
you boy it'll be ready there it is
you stirred ham oh I'd give it to PB
it's in vir
oh my god we're transcending mediums
[Music]
[Laughter]
taught me to always go for what you want
without any danny davito there's open my
life to so many new experiences that I
never would even dream to be possible
yeah I'm not ready for this level q how
long is this oh my god I love this style
of this step thought I was there
everyone was there
nice we wanted to have our dogs there so
badly or an allowed to keep them at the
conservatory people said they like
low-effort cakeday memes so here you go
is this supposed to be low effort effort
today's your cake day so you 3d printed
a cake okay but then it's not a real
cake what's the point
you painted it blue okay you put the
ship okay I so far I can do this
you make bling blong alright got it
hello anyone can use glue come on okay
that's pretty cool hey it counts on your
cake day I'll never understand why
anyone gives such time it's it's your
birthday yeah but it's not my goddamn
cake day so watch that point
reddit nerds I mean it's a cool equation
don't get me wrong
Sorry Sorry Sorry before I cheated on
him thanks for an amazing after I
cheated things change
got pain you deserve it you it's on you
stop shifting bling recognize your own
mistakes and learn from them why is it
so hard for people that do that my god
watch mother shapes doctor head after
she bullies girl with cancer yeah she
deserves it good good mom that's good
parenting right there are you winning
doctor yes now you are shameless
shameless shape peach should make a
weekly cooking service and call it sweet
dish
when these days okay girl from KL
alright you said it on that guy I did
feel like cooking with PewDiePie is kind
of not cringe but lazy format so yeah
alright Swedish cooking yeah yeah yeah
any Swedish man invent something Felix
our invention it's our invention yeah I
mean I'm not saying I invented the am
beef separator that is the Swedish
invention and that many people benefit
from all I'm saying is Irish inventions
you helped put a man on the moon that's
that's rich we helped guys yes so that I
am with paying taxes what about it why
do you get a medal in metal they helped
out took away pain they revolutionize
farming
good job Ireland milk chocolate useless
don't ever come at me about your and
your country's inventions because you'll
never win oh my god oh oh oh hell yeah
freaky Dickies that's a OH
oh yeah yes slidin melons left and right
there it is okay Instagram cam bar check
them out 10 out of 10 after 20 years of
dvelopment tambourine stacker game for
Android is released
tambourine stacker oh it's got a 4.7
rating alright here we go
tambourine stacker everybody I get to
choose to tilt or drag I'll drag alright
okay nice ah is this so difficult to put
the liquid I mean the controls are great
this is the best game I've ever seen
yeah
yes good oh it's like okay here we go
we got it the goal come on yeah it's
pretty cool
what is Maya do I get a big peepee brain
oh she's sitting with me I didn't see
then oh my god it controls man I missed
that guests I did it somehow I'm too
strong alright that's a fun little game
check it out thanks for making that
mythical water so I was making fun of it
but it's really fun thank you that's
awesome oh my god
another beautify introvert dog version I
[Applause]
love these you never know what you can I
get next we go from VR to dog right away
whoa the aesthetic man goddamn that's so
cool oh oh the details whoa cool jouvert
best boy damn I know it's uh it's made
by Adi Adi Oh God
get arcing
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
please send me more I could play
Tambourine two more songs if you guys
want to cover up a tambourine song just
to send it to me make sure it's not
copyrighted okay we have IKEA the anime
hell yeah sure I'll help [ __ ] boo letter
village good acoustics 50 huge B P
that's amazing recorded took the picture
mmm no I was Maya Maya took the picture
all right we got animal crossing version
[Music]
nice nice nice nice nice dude we got
enough interest to last us the rest of
the year keep up coming it's working
almost 106 million subscribers we got
him we got him guys it's not even a
challenge petition for Felix to cut by a
snails
oh my god Maya is really old the part of
her nail that is like part of her blood
vessels is really spread out so I have
to cut her nails really frequently and
unfortunately they do look very long but
I can only cut a little bit otherwise
she starts bleeding and she gets in a
lot of pain so we just cut her nails
frequently oh yeah she probably needs to
cut but it's not like we're slacking up
we're taking good care of our dogs it's
literally something we can't really do
much about enough editing side here have
a break here you go side
have a kit kat you're welcome no no
galleries pointless galleries wudu you
know throw gang you eat protein pre art
protein nothing else zebra meat let's
get it
[Laughter]
are you really making a French but I
didn't mean yes oh man that felt good
yes yes yes yes no some good lately man
some good I'm just happy I like it I
like it too locked there we go
it's my cake de material only people
starting my new muds are gay sub to be
the pie floor again I told you bro I
told you everybody has cake today
you ain't special you ain't nothing my
girlfriend broke up with me because she
heard me shouting hey Monica and thought
I was cheating oh hey Monica would be a
good tambourine cover and also sorry
about your girlfriend bro Jesus Christ
PewDiePie's intro toddlers it's gone
goddamn they all fall for it they're so
dumb their brains are underdeveloped
brains are so stupid sigh when he
realized that he doesn't need to do the
intro anymore because other people are
doing it for him
yes I'm just shelling now he's like yeah
we got those ten-second cupboard in
Sweden it's forbidden by law to be a
criminal
Wow we did it boys crime is no more we
got big brain we're operations here in
Sweden okay I said here in Sweden the
basic intro said the separate versus the
hey I love democracy so I can't go
against Versailles pigs might SIA be
deep I deliver of tambourine
based on true story yeah but it's how
that going went down are we winning dead
no poor that's right
got up alright this looks amazing
people had a problem with this it's cool
yeah it's nice different styles I love
the different styles on these so this is
YouTube Iraq and they do too freaking
genius he's 180 centimeter tall she
could possibly be longer but God okay
I'm talking different dimensions
destroying and killing memes genius all
right
but this guy this frickin guy decides at
fricken I'm bored and in turns himself
into the most outrageous thing some are
that dude turns himself into a melon a
frickin melon funniest kid I've ever
seen sorry let go of my neck please I'm
scared
you said we would only be five minutes
very nice society if Sweden didn't take
this you are welcome you are welcome we
just want to thanks huh name one
character that went through more pain
than her Jeb yep Jeb
pain pain go away pain understandable
have a great day
understandable I'll go away oh we got a
sound oh oh
the quality is too good I can almost
read the subtitles oh there we go since
my internet my but what is happening No
I have a lot to learn No
[Music]
the floor this is pathetic did one day
one day I'll return mark my flippin
words open your mouth open your mouth
kiss it you see yes you have been
blessed normal person so what did Sweden
invent Felix it's true don't you dare
not say thanks are you winning Marzia
yet it did Felix a key player but did
they be actin a I mean accurate to be
honest oh my god Edgar gets an intro
[Applause]
[Music]
alright that's cool guys getting million
subscribers by uploading frequent
commentary about what she picked cooking
it was video games you're about 5 years
too early when was that I got to see the
original I've seen this yeah I've seen
this has gained millions of subscribers
by uploading frequent commentary about
what thinking pies and cooking
[Music]
so you've worked in cooking well that's
where you're wrong mother
Nikki knows her game right there are you
winning son yes I give life to the all
the earth and this universe other
youtubers sorry guys the video quality
might be seen what the hell no why is it
did 4k 60fps PewDiePie mr. King do you
720p we know the why content hey if it
works they works this is my apology
number two this time I am apologizing
for nothing that's right I apologize
that have nothing to apologize for
I apologize for being unproblematic
youtuber for way too long
what the flip dude are you - peep I was
like oh that is very easy guess it's no
unsubscribe so sorry guys it's been like
one a year since my last controversy oh
I'm ashamed but I will try to do better
I will work on bettering myself and
improving and worse I will work on
worsening myself and making bigger
mistakes in the future I'll make a
mistake so big that hopefully it will
redeem my yeah I'm so sorry guys it PD
PI isn't he the guy that just best
controversies of purpose stay relevant
no but I don't need it
suck a PP did you know that if a
restaurant messes up your order you can
simply say oh actually I had instead of
screaming at the 16 year old employee
and they will still fix it for you
yeah that's fair that is fair my
strategy is always before I get angry I
double check because it's so easy to do
you got to hear their side first
and if they sit back up and they say
guys stand their ground then you can get
angry like sometimes things can just be
a misunderstanding but
to misunderstandings then they die then
they get the wrath of the floor gang oh
god what is this just oh my god nice
nice nice nice
very good petition for the boys to make
another one of these yeah that's fun
three years ago dude YouTube right this
clickbait wait that's legal PewDiePie
this click Pig understandable and this
have a great day
what do you mean I don't never click
thing I just made the apology that's the
title of the video what's the problem
the world if Sweden didn't invent the
crew a B cream separator yeah pretty
much say thanks on behalf of all of us
are you winning piers when when window
matter what I mean of course I'm winning
I got a tambourine power that I was
planning to grow ones every million
subscribers and it's growing so fast
that a guy can't keep up thought it
would be bigger by now but that's okay
that's fine
who are these people with their stupid
thumbnails stop it you're making me look
way shorter I draw Piet's and gravity
falls style very cool very nice I like
it
damn alright clearly I'm a little bit
more of a fan of this one sorry the
other one but they like this one I like
this one a lot PewDiePie I grew up
watching Pokemon so it's Swedish me I
grew up watching PewDiePie so Xindian me
as a German who watched the World Cup as
a child no yeah looks awesome PD PI 9
month old 19 when people gets caught in
zipper I'll never forget that switch
that's right Sweden TP invention the
zipper was Swedish invention you're
welcome PP stuck in zip
oh it's hand-drawn alright well yeah no
no stop the he's burrito glasses please
[Music]
make it look so real spoopy since our
daughter has been a recent victim good
[Music]
yeah very nice oh my god I'm done I'm
freakin done no more apologies I
apologize for my apologies how about
that yeah that's it for this week's love
why thank you for the amazing
submissions as always super fun like
subscribe like and subscribe like
subscribe like subscribe I'm dead inside
come on let's get a game where see you
guys manana
Hey
[Music]
it's time to race what was once
forgotten
what creatures fart spells and poop
troops awaits
50 is coming to Nintendo's wait and
remember it has a very big TV pre-order
promotion timing
[Music]
jmes checkbook birthday girl ran away